hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast comparative genome and
transcriptome analysis small cell
numbers I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab
birds and I'll be your moderator for
today's event lad routes comm is the
leading scientific social networking
site and we are proud to bring you this
interactive web seminars and more
information visit us at Lazarus com
here's how this presentation works we
want to hear from you questions comments
and even answers can be submitted via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of your screen will try to get everyone
but if not we'll make sure to follow
follow up the views like Nina you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide link if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the statistic
at the top right or the Q&A button in
the lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speakers dr. Christian
Corphish dr. Christian collage dis
director R&B scientific applications
cryogen in hilden his responsibilities
include the development and evaluation
of new amplification and assay
technologies and solutions for single
cell research dr coeur fogs joins Biogen
in 1997 and has held various positions
in research and development in the areas
real-time pcr methods isothermal
amplification methods and single cell
technology for more information about
our speakers please click on his name to
know about his background um I'll turn
it over dr kourosh thank you very much
Brenda welcome everybody I hope you
enjoy the next hour of our webinar I
would like to talk about the functional
linkage between the genome and
transcriptome which can be decoded by
the comparative genome and transcriptome
analysis of small cell numbers the talk
needs about 45 minutes and then we will
prepare further 50 minutes also for
questions and answers I would like to
under law I would like
underline that the products i talked
about are for research use only all or
though the products can use for the
analysis of cancer cells for example
none of them is intended for diagnosis
that disease prevention or disease
treatment so this is a little overview
about my talk at first I would like to
give a brief introduction into the topic
of cancer development I will present a
very few slide for single-cell genomics
and single cells transformed
transcriptomics which are very useful
analysis methods for cancer research but
the main part represents a topic of
support the comparative genome and
transcriptome analysis of the small of
of the same sample so coming to a very
little introduction to cancer
development most likely cancer is
developed from a single found ourselves
seen here on on the left side this
little founder cell comprises mutations
that result in uncontrolled cell
divisions in otherwise differentiated
tissue during further cell divisions
more and more mutations accumulate in
daughter cells some of these daughter
cells will die but others can generate
further mutated daughter cells finally
the cancer tissue consists of various
clones of cells with a huge variety of
different genomes some of these cells
may migrate to form with metastasis
recording for example to Lawson who
published a little publication in nature
last week cells founding metastasis or
cell founding metastasis show us them
like expression pattern but so all kinds
of mutations can occur during cancer
evolution but most striking in cancer
evolution are structural in numerical
chromosome changes in karyotypes in the
final stage of cancer
in 2011 Nicholas Navin dissected tumor
tissues in small sections in order to
analyze genomic changes occurred in
these sectors we found cells here in
green that show no or only minor changes
in chromosome numbers in other sectors
like this blue yellow or red sectors he
found a strong degree of an oil reading
scene and the panels on the right side
on of this slide finally cancer tissue
comprises highly annoyed poetic cells as
seen here in the karyotype on the right
side it was found that the karyotype of
many cells is highly variable within a
tumor sample in order to analyze the
influence of genome changes on the
transcriptome it is necessary to use
cell clones with a small cell number
question are going to need to know what
sliding they are I mean this is slide 7
can you see that okay final so so to
make sure that effects are not diluted
by various genotypes one has to use very
tiny cell numbers or sell clothes to
make sure that these are derived from
the same genotype today is a highly
attractive technology for genome and
transcriptome analysis is
next-generation sequencing or NGS but
NGS technology requires more nucleic
acids for analysis and that what is
packed within a few cells which you
would like to analyze from the cancer
tissue there for whole genome
amplification is necessary
re for DNA analysis and whole
transcriptome amplification is necessary
for RNA analysis on slide eight you can
see that a little overview about our
product portfolio for single cell
applications we offer three different
kids for the amplification of DNA or RNA
from very small cell numbers down to a
single cell and two new kids are
launched that couples the amplification
of RNA or DNA and library prep for NGS
slide 9 coming to single-cell genomics
as I said before tumors may have evolved
various genomes within a single cancer
tissue the more evolved a tumor is the
more genome changes were occurred the
replica single circuit is made for
cropping the cellular DNA of single
cells for further analysis for example
for NGS ideally is a DNA that is
generated by the whole genome
amplification process must be a perfect
copy of the template DNA of the single
settle that means without bias or
without arrows in order to minimize
errors during the DNA amplification
method of single-cell DNA we use the
proofreading v29 polymerase in our case
the refugee single cell chip is senior
right in the in the middle of the of the
slide 10 is a whole genome amplification
method using 1 to 1,000 cells as
starting material and the method uses
the fee 29 / owner polymerase as I said
before the P 29 polymerase is polymerase
with high proofreading activity and this
is very important a strong DNA strand
displacement activity
which is highly suitable to run also
through hairpin structures you can start
with single cells directly so no DNA
preparation is necessary and in the
upper box you can see the repligen
single cell library clip which couples
wga and ngos library preparation for NGS
in order to show the performance very
briefly you can see our NGS results of
some of our NGS results in slide 11 we
stress through the refugee whole genome
amplification process by testing
bacterial cells of course bacterial
cells compared comprise very tiny
genomes that are roughly 1,000 forward
smaller than the human cancer genome
therefore the amplification rate must be
much higher than with human cancer cells
if starting from bacterial cells and
arrows will be more pronounced because
of this higher amplification rate
starting from two to five cells this is
not more than 10 to 25 phantograms of
bacterial cells of the bacterial DNA
about 30 to 40 micro gram of DNA is
generated this corresponds to an
amplification factor of several billion
forward and the amplified amplified DNA
was used for library prep and
next-generation sequencing and the
result I've seen on the right side of
this slide 11 if doing so we found no
side products generated during the wga
process this is indicated by the finding
that up to 99 percent of the reads
mapped perfectly to the bacterial genome
here we saw almost the same performance
with forward and reverse sequencing
reads which indicates that this WTA
DNA is highly suitable for NGS reading
looking for error rates in flight 12
despite on the billion fold
amplification the rate of arrows
insertions deletions or chimeras is very
very low looking on the error rate for
example the values are indistinguishable
between NGS data obtained after a
replica amplification or with non
amplified DNA below this makes so the
wga DNA is highly suitable for NGS
without introducing arrows or insertions
and deletions below you find a reference
for a detailed protocol that describes
the whole process from the cell the two
wga and up to NGS so this protocol is
published in 2013 in current protocols
of molecular biology coming to a very
little details on single-cell
transcriptomics our WTA kid is made for
cropping the RNA transcript home of a
single or more cells to discover what is
different between individual cells for
example in cancer tissue various
protocols are offered where you choose
between all the good ET primer or random
primers to select for the RNA of your
interest for example the amplification
process uses once again the proofreading
329 polymerase but in this case here we
use modified 329 polymerase with a
higher affinity to very small seed in a
amongst the revenue GWT a kid seen here
in the middle of Sir
slide 14 can be used for whole
transcriptome amplification from 1 to
1,000 cells we tested also slightly
higher higher cell numbers which are
which work also fine but I would
recommend the thousand cells as upper
line of this kit again you start the
process directly from single cells known
there is no need for sample prep and the
process is divided into three steps
first the reverse transcription to
devise the cdna which is ligated
thereafter in the second step and in the
third step we have a the ligated cdna
which is amplified there in the upper
box you can see again the refugee single
cells are in a library kit which couples
WTA and NGS library prep in slide 15 we
see some results we could show a high
sample to sample correlation of gene
expression profiles after whole
transcriptome amplification using the
refugee WT a single cell kit with very
low cell numbers the transcripts of
about nine thousand genes could be
detected it routinely and in total the
refugee wpa method amplifies RNA very
reproducible from single cells so that
the unbuttons that the abundance of
thousands of mRNAs can be can be
reproducible analyzed on this life you
can see what you expect from data
analysts analysis using variable cell
numbers this is really typical the
scatter plot shows that most spots are
very close to the diagonal with little
exceptions if looking on high cell
numbers like 50-75 cells or 10 cells but
with low cell numbers and this is very
typical more exceptions
are expected and seen in this case which
are based on individual transcriptome
differences with up with in single cells
so this patterning with low cell numbers
underlines what was said by Jim Deaver
line for example on a single-cell
genomics conference and would be traced
very recently he mean every cell is
unique and this is a year underlined by
this free cell cell analysis below you
find again a reference of a detailed
protocol from the single cells to WTA
and NGS also in current protocols so
coming now to the main topic of the
webinar in order to decode how genomic
changes change the expression profile we
compare the genome in the transcriptome
of the same sample by NGS for doing so
it is necessary that all steps necessary
prior to NGS are highly comparable
between genome and transcriptome
analysis and are adapted to each other
so that if bias is introduced it is most
likely the same for the genome and the
transcriptomic material so we use in our
study the refugee cell wga in WP a kit
for the amplification of cellular DNA
and RNA of the same sample in slide that
70 you see is a rebel EG cell wga WT
take it in this box and in the last box
in in a highly paralyzed process wga
wwta is performed from the same sample
and this process can be started directly
from 25 cells up to 1,000 cells without
an extra purification step for RNA or
DNA at first I would like to introduce
comparative transcriptome and genome NGS
analysis in the next slide so one
central concept in biology is that the
phenotype of cells is realized based on
the genome as a basic information memory
but this means that the genome
determines how the cell reacts or at
least how the transcriptome is changed
upon the triggers are a changing
environment if information that is fixed
in the genome is changed as in cancer
cells for example that means the
sequence is different from the origin
the transcriptome will react in a
different way of course not every change
in base composition will change also the
transcription profile but changes in
promoters or changes in coding regions
changes in chromosome structure or copy
number often change the transcription
profile these changes in genomic
sequences are often seen in cancer
tissues many tumors are a mosaic of
various genotypes and result accordingly
to a mosaic of various cell behaviors
please remember that different tumor
cells react differently for example upon
antitumor therapies and a very few cells
survive eventually because of their
judgement genomes
in order to discover which changes of
the Cancer Genome drives specific
changes in the transcript transcription
profile the analysis method has to meet
a few requirements at first the same
cancer sample has to be analyzed for
genome and expression profile analysis
second because RNA and DNA share
partially the same sequence the reaction
for RNA and DNA must be split as long as
necessary to get individual results from
the transcriptome and the genome ideally
NGS has to be performed in the same run
third all processing steps necessary for
the comparative analysis should be
identical for RNA and DNA and forth
because the genome changes are often
found in mosaic like patterns in tumors
the analysis must work also for small
samples comprising only a few cells and
a small number of you few cells require
wga and WTA from the same sample for NGS
analysis and below again you find a
detailed protocol for parallel wga WTA
that describes the process from the
cells to wga and WTA and NGS and the
process was again published in Mullica
in current protocols here you can see it
is inside the 20 you can see the revenue
gewgaw GA and WTA workflow in more
detail this repligen method comprises a
highly parallel process that starts with
the lysis of the sample the lysis
process make sure that every cell is
lized and all look like assets that
means Erin are RNA as well as DNA are
stabilized
after the lysis the material is split
and distanced 22 reaction tubes for
further parallel processing in WG A&W TV
after GD in a removal WTA start with the
reverse transcription to then generate
cdna and because the p29 polymerase
needs very large DNA molecules the
ligation of all see DNA fragments is the
only way how cdna is channeled into a V
29 polymerase based amplification so
finally the amplification is performed
by an by repligen like reaction using
the new genetically engineered 329
enzyme which I mentioned before this
free 29 mate enzyme has a higher
affinity to low DNA amounts of this
highly suitable for this reaction
therefore to make sure that WTA and WG
is performed in the same way we adapted
the first steps to w of w GA to the
process needed for WTA so the process
here described as a wga rig ready
reaction on the right side here results
in DNA fragments of similar size found
after seeding a thin pieces and
therefore a ligation and amplification
asst or a ligation this is needed and
the ligation and amplification is simply
the same for wga and WTA so this is a
really a highly highly paralyzed process
and every day every step is kept very
similar during WTA and BW g a reaction
from the same sample we applied the
method on a cancer cell lines the HeLa
cells for in this case because a healthy
Reverend cell line was not available we
use huvec cells as a ref
rennes material we were interested how
the genome copy number determines gene
expression so our experiment is based on
hela cells and and who reg cells of
course which differ highly in the degree
of pro EDT and expression profile of
course in average hela cells our trip
tree blew it cancer cells with a high
copy number variability among the
chromosomes some chromosomes such as
chromosome 4 for example are deployed
while other chromosomes are tetra buried
and some chromosomal regions are even
penned up lead for example so in
contrast huvec cells are primary cells
which are deep blue it only so in order
to determine the impact of chromosome
number on the expression profile we
compare the Gila and the gugak cells on
the genome and the transcriptome level
the experiment is shown in all the the
experiment workflow is shown in slide 22
and the experiment started in either
case with 50 cells using 50 hela cells
of 50 rubik cells and the cells are
alive and the sample was split for WGN
WTA reactions and after amplification
individual bar-coded library preps were
done using the gene read library prep
kit and my seek sequencing was performed
for wga in WTA samples so after
sequencing bioinformatic analysis was
performed with the galaxy programs in
this case I cannot see slide 23 are now
it's there in this slide I want to
mention that we determine numerical
changes of chromosomes or sub
chromosomal regions by Counting read
in after mgs and this counting reads
were mapped to mega base parabens of
chromosomal regions we determined a
factor between hela cells and lube axles
because who excels are deployed as I
said before the hectare describes the
deviation from diploid copy number in
hela cells for example a factor or
higher than 1 corresponds to a higher
copy number of the indicated genomic
region and in hela cells compared to who
excels and looking on NGS data from the
WTA cdna we met all reads to the
transcriptome and the RP came well use
of all transcripts we're determined and
compared between Gila and who excels we
selected for differentially expressed
genes present in both cell lines these
transcripts were then mapped to their
corresponding chromosomal locals and
after the alignment of the
differentially expressed genes with a
copy number variation determined from
genomic reads we can determine determine
how the copy number drives the gene
expression so this is a analysis we did
to determine how the genome determines
the transcriptome or the expression
profile at first I want to present some
primary findings in this case the bio
type pattern and the bio type pattern
was very similar between Gila and who
excels we found that most reads after
WTA met to protein-coding regions only
though only less than ten ten percent of
the reads cannot be mapped to the human
target sequence so most of the reeds
maps to the transcriptome please see but
please look on the bass at the right
side of this y-axis or
most no reads are met to rrna in this
case this is a good indication that our
reverse transcription is highly
selective for mrna in this case if using
our oligo dt priming during cdna
synthesis we found more than 20,000
transcript from about nine thousand
genes and we found a highly reputed
reproducibility from sample to sample
which can be determined from the scatter
plots here Caleb as versus Gila in panel
a or huvec versus who excels in panel B
if looking on the panel see you find the
comparison of HeLa cells on the x-axis
to who excels on the y-axis and that
shows more differences which are also
indicated by a lower r square well you
so there is a clear difference in gene
expression profile between healer and
two egg cells need for a wife or a
switch to slide 27
hello okay in in slide 27 you can see
panel d and in penalty only those
transcripts with our peak am well you
higher than 10 were analyzed so you can
see a big overlap of genes co-expressed
anila in huvec cells but there are also
a significant number of genes expressed
only in one of these cell lines for our
further analysis we focus only on those
about 5,800 genes which are coexpressed
in ela and in huvec cells we further
selected for genes that are
differentially expressed with a
difference of at least three forward if
there is a differentially expressed
differentially expression lower than
this we excluded those transcripts so as
I said we analyzed all all those
transcripts that are differentially
expressed in Lubec and hela cells with a
factor of at least three fold and we met
these genes of those of those
transcripts to the chromosomal low sigh
and found that more genes showed higher
expression rate in hela than in huvec
cells this is indicated by the light
blue bar or the light blue sector of the
bars the genes hi are expressed in
huvecs than in hela cells are indicated
by the dark blue sectors in the bars at
first looking on the light blue sectors
within the bars in average more than
seventy percent of differentially
expressed genes are expressed at a
higher level in hela cells only let less
than thirty percent of the genes are
expressed at a higher level in huvec
cells this is very striking you but
there are also exceptions these these
exceptions are the genes on chromosomes
414 and
team all three chromosomes harbor almost
equal number of genes that I expressed
at a higher level in hela cells or a
higher level in huvec cells so in order
to explain this effect at first I want
to deduce what is expected from this
experiment so what is our expectation is
focusing on the gene expression of genes
of comparing hey line dobok cells please
keep in mind that healer and huvec cells
are of different origin and as seen
before genes are differentially
expressed in hela cells and huvec cells
and of course it is obvious from many
studies that different cells show
different expression profiles so what we
do Express from this experiment because
we use in our analysis only those genes
that expressed in both cell lines the
number of genes that are overexpressed
in hela cells must resemble the number
of genes that are overexpressed in huvec
cells at least if you focus on genes in
deeply chromosomal regions but how is
the number of over expressed genes and
regions with a chromosome number
different from 2n in this slide you can
see what we have analyzed from our NGS
experiment after parallel WGN WTA
looking on the copy number of chromosome
4 and eight only the black dotted line
indicates the chromosome number in hela
cells compared to avec cells which we
calculated from the number of reads in
our NGS experiment chromosome 4 is about
as it is about 180 mb mega bases like
length long and chromosome 8 has a
length of about 150 mega bases I have
to refresh my connection here on moment
can you see anything I can supply / DT
question 32 because i cannot see that
Scott 32 yes so sorry for this
inconvenience I can see only i can t
know slide at the moment and i would
like to follow up with a slide 31 okay i
hope
can you slide can you see slide 31 I
cannot really just continue and you can
let us know what playa para member i
would like to mention that it is pretty
clear that the factor is around 1 for
the whole chromosome 4 this means the
chromosome 4 has the same copy number in
here ourselves as in huvec cells because
the copy number in huvec cells is 2n the
HeLa cells are also two chromosomes of
chromosome 4 so the HeLa cells used for
this experiment comprise or is quite
normal with regards to chromosome for
the situation is completely different
where's chromosome 8 here the short arm
is also deep lead but the long arm of
the chromosome 8 is mostly tetra to eat
with some cheap to eat patches then we
met all the differentially expressed
genes located on chromosome for all
those jeans with at least a three four
different the gene expression rate
between rubik and heal ourselves so can
you switch to 32 can you do this take
you on okay we found what we expected
namely the number of genes that are
expressed and heal ourselves to a higher
level resemble the number of genes that
are overexpressed in rubic cells if we
focus on this nipple each chromosome 4
so what we do see or what do we see here
in this panel the expression level of
the HeLa cells compared to reg cells
seen on the y-axis each red square
represents our genes that is
differentially expressed
and the position of the Red Square with
regards to these axis indicates a
mapping position to the chromosome the
position of the Red Square with regards
to the y-axis here indicates a factor of
gene expression in hela cells compared
to reg cells and that means that square
is higher than one for example indicates
genoqs the genes that are expressed in
ourselves and squares that are below 1
corresponds to genes that are work
stress and deplete who excels here so
and the arrow bars indicate the
variation between different samples so
in summary once again the number of
genes that are expressed in in ourselves
to at a higher level resemble the number
of genes that are overexpressed in
living cells if we focus on this on this
deeply each chromosome so switching to
slide 31 33 then we met also the
differentially then we met also the
differentially expressed genes located
on chromosome 8 to the low side and
found for the deplete region of
chromosome 8 the same pattern we got for
the decreed chromosome 4 but most
regions of the chromosome 8 a tetra to
eat or at least three triplet indeed
seen ourselves we analyzed here these
pulley fleet regions in hela cells the
number of genes overexpressed in hela
cells exceeds the rap dramatically the
number of genes always expressed in the
deeply to beg cells in this region only
a single gene is more expressed in huvec
cells compared to the pelicula taylor
cells so here you can see that the copy
number of the genome region determines
the number of over expressed genes in
hela cells can use which to slide 34
so and looking on other depleted
chromosomes in hela cells such as
chromosome 14 and 18 again the number of
genes overexpressed in hela cells
resembles the number of genes
overexpressed in huvec cells just as
expected from deplete genome regions
switching to slide 35 and now I would
like to look on the other pulley clue a
clue pelicula eat chromosomal regions
such as chromosome 7 10 or 5 it is the
same situation as with the crows on 8
and the number of genes overexpressed in
triplet or tetra fluid regions in hela
cells exceeds the number of genes
overexpressed in the deeply 2xl line but
in this case you find more exceptions
for example on the long arm of
chromosome 10 might be valuable to
analyze the reasons of this exceptional
low expression rates of these genes so
coming to slide 36 this pattern that
more over expressed genes in hela cells
are found on Polly put genomic regions
holds true for most chromosomes in the
cancer cell line most chromosomes are
poly blew it in hela cells only the
chromosomes for 14 and 18 are employed
in our he loves airline so see the light
blue sectors within the bars but these
resembles the number of open express
genes per million base pairs so small
chromosome 21 is very extreme here all
genes that are located on chromosome 21
are overexpressed in here ourselves and
there is no genes which is overexpressed
in huvec cells so the copy number of
chromosome
21 revealed that chromosome 21 is tree
blew it in our HeLa cell line and it was
found in various studies that the
fluidity of chromosome 21 is very
variable in in ourselves and ranges from
two and two foreign in different HeLa
cell lines their highest density of
differentially expressed genes was found
on chromosome 19 this is not unexpected
because in human cells chromosome 19
harbors the highest gene density per se
so coming to slide 37 and I would like
to summarize I think I could show the
comparative analysis of genome and the
transcriptome is a useful tool to
determine genomic effects on the
expression profile and of course how
changes within the genome change also
the expression profile we developed the
refugee cell wga nwt a kid as a tool to
provide you with a method to amplify
cellular DNA and RNA from the saints
small samples with high quality and low
bias so that comparative analysis can be
performed so a highly parallel process
introduce minimal bias and results in
comparable amplification rates for the
same sequences within the genome and
transcriptome so we could show that the
method is highly suitable for NGS
because a proofreading polymerase is
used and no arrows are introduced and
the feed 29 polymerase has a strong DNA
displacement activity so that happen
structures with within nucleic acids do
not inhibit amplification so slide 38
thank you for your attention and slide
39 the session is open now for questions
thank you
for that informative presentation we
want to get right to the questions and
input so here's a reminder on how to let
us know what you have to say questions
do is submitted via the Q&A button at
the lower left we try to get all of you
does not so be sure to follow up after
the broadcast our first question can I
do the analysis also with ffpe material
this is a good question we I think or
let me answer in a different way we
haven't tried so far we know that we
have in FFPE samples the DNA as well as
the RNA is blocked by covalent bound
proteins for example and this is this
hinders the amplification process so i
would not recommend this process with
with this with a skip using a delta g
FFPE samples but at the moment we are
doing some studies on it may be that in
a in a year or so that we can have more
details on it great sounds promising our
next question what is the minimum little
shelf I can use for the analysis I I did
the study here with 50 cells and we
found that 25 cells is fine as well but
because you do do you split the sample
into two wires for wga and for WTA it is
clear that you have a poisson
distribution effect on it so if good
doing with if doing the analysis with 25
cells is fine but with lower cell
numbers you
have more variability especially on the
part of wga because every cell comprises
only a single genome not more and if you
divide this 25 genomes into two tubes
you have you let you have only 12 and 5
12 genomes left in one tube and this is
for poison this distribution affects its
but better to have more days or at least
these 12 genomes in it great thank you
uh next question is there a difference
in Angeles library prep it's starting
from WTA DNA or WG a DNA this is a good
question after WTA you you end up with a
DNA as well as after wga and both
samples are absolutely of the same
quality and comprises the same molecular
white for example for DNA and cdna so
you can start with the same process
using the WTA and wga DNA and the
process started with fragmentation of
wga DNA and fragmentation of WTA DNA and
afterwards you do your library prep so
there is no difference in handling of
WTA DNA or WT ad and a to a channel it
these DNA's included NGS process great
thank you for them we have time for one
more question cannon from University of
Toledo asks for the single so
transcriptomic for Jews that have a low
expression that there's some idea of the
time under cutoff might be
this is with regards to the kid I I
mentioned in the single-cell
transcriptomic session and we found it
it works sign with a single cells but of
course you have various copies and copy
numbers of various transcripts within
single cell and we found that with very
low copy numbers it is a there is a
cutoff value of the detection
probability I would say so if you have
one copy for example then you have a
given detection probability with ten
copies copy number with ten copies
within a single cell we found in most
cases that that those transcripts are
represented after WTA but they cannot be
quantified because of the again because
of poison this poison effects on reverse
transcription ligation and amplification
if having more than these ten copies
then you get a better and better chance
to quantify also those transcripts but
once again below 10 copies you have a
good chance to get the copies but you
cannot quantify it and you need more
copies for a quantification for a good
quantification with the high with a low
variability great thank you we're done
with questions now I just like to ask
Christian if he has any final comments
or thoughts for our audience
not from my side okay thank you for that
important information if we weren't able
to speak directly with you today we'll
be sure to follow up with any of your
comments and questions we want to thank
you for taking part we also want to see
today's presenters for joining up here
at lab routes comm the meeting
scientific social networking site for
more information please visit us at
wwe.com today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing on our
website to march of 2016 we'll let you
know when it and post it when we help
you pass that information on to any
colleagues who couldn't take part in
today's broadcast thank you very much
see you next time the guy